[Music]
so
this author named mark dawson
i don't like him recently lost his top
10 position in the sunday times
seller charts damn how many periods does
this sentence have
none there are zero periods the sunday
time
every single word has a period yes she
lost it yeah so
he recently lost his position it was a
long menopause
mental pause because there's no periods
get it and she paused yeah and he's a
man and he's a man
that was good what the [ __ ] horrifying
you had to explain it for me to get it
yeah i was like does it work
oh it does i only pretend like it's
cringy as [ __ ] but i think it's [ __ ]
awesome
you all take it makes me want to throw
up love it yes
i feel like the quality of our channels
going down
she's got two drinks with that hair joe
come on
yeah this is i'm trying to raise up the
bar look at you in my head right now oh
let me know this [ __ ] cuz i gotta know
what are we doing i'm doing one in the
back and i'm loosening up the okay
okay okay how do you have no
hair tied dance huh
you've been having a hair tie this whole
time you don't have any dents in your
hair what the dents mean
there's a dent i think his hand is like
crazy thick that's why
so i got this one and then i do this can
you can you
okay i think it's similar yeah anyway
back to this story
so this author the reason why he lost
his top 10 position
for best seller for his book which is a
thriller called the cleaner
was after he revealed in a podcast that
he bought
400 copies oh you [ __ ] guy himself
he's like the guy that buys bots to
increase his views on youtube
he's a follower buyer oh yeah so he said
that he ordered 400
hardback copies of his book with a
children's book shop in
this other place for a cost of 3 600
british pounds
and he said that he was motivated to do
this because he saw that he was in the
13th spot
on nielsen's midweek chart which is in
the sunday times
and so uh so he he ended up contacting
readers overseas to see if they would
purchase
this book and so he ended up buying 400
copies
to sell to these other readers in other
countries in order for him to get the
top ten position
that's why shut up shut up it's about
the second part not the first part
i like how they were in other countries
and i bet they don't even speak or read
english
right so i'll sell you this for two
cents i'll pay you yeah i'm sending
them to ethiopia it'll be it's a good
deal it's funny because he could totally
just
get the book wholesale and then send it
to him instead of ordering it through
the store
well then he wouldn't get the talk uh
also he wanted to
manipulate it right right so then uh he
ended up
moving up to the eighth place in the
sunday times hardback fiction list
and so once they discovered that he
mentioned the fact that he purchased
these
400 books himself on a podcast that's
when they were like hold on why would he
mention it
he was bragging how did they not know
he's like i game the system
so that's what a lot of people are are
claiming right that he was trying to
game the system
and his response to that on twitter he
said of course i was
i'd be sick i know right but instead why
wouldn't i
he said if i if i was intense on gaming
the system
i would have bought 10k copies sat on
them forever
and been number one i wouldn't have
discussed it on a popular podcast
it doesn't have the money to spend 20
g's probably right what are we talking
about
i don't know it's like he gets the money
directly either because
there's a percentage taken out for your
publisher and all in all so wait i just
have to buy 3 000
wait 400 books of my own well he had
already sat on the 13th spot
so to get up into the top 10 which
landed him eighth
eighth spot was 400 books so this is
mark dude the [ __ ] we all do for ego is
wild isn't it
it is cool i've never gotten a trophy so
i feel like i would
i would be like oh i finally got a
trophy
yeah but you could go to a trophy store
buy one and then hang it in your house
see if you knew you bought the trophy it
sucks though
it does suck you didn't earn it that's
true i i don't like that part about it
but what if he felt like he earned the
public knowing that he got this spot
like it's like
it's still a game well would you feel
better
if like in his situation where he bought
these books
to sell to other readers so technically
you're not just sitting on these books
you would be giving it to other readers
i don't know it sounds like a lot of
work
it is a lot of work yeah [ __ ] yeah plus
what did he buy them all under his own
name like what the [ __ ]
how do you buy it doesn't that already
raise a few [ __ ] flags
it would feel bad that people didn't
actually want to buy my story
we got the top 13 pretty good yeah but
this ranking system
sounds pretty low yeah like no one
[ __ ]
you can with 400 books i mean it's not
like the new york times
seller yeah that one actually those are
surprisingly low too yeah those are
really low too
but not in the hundreds not the hundreds
no no
but think about how many people are
actually actually buying books like
i love buying books i tried a kindle for
the first time this past month
and i don't like it that much oh it's
not the same as a physical
ages like feelings yeah two that's
[ __ ] ridiculous
i thought they counted i get kendall oh
i'll probably get three i get audio can
the same book yeah damn yeah why do you
do that
because i'm always doing different
things so it depends like if i want to
do nighttime reading then i have my
kindle if i'm driving in the car then
i'm listening to it and then if i have
actual time to just relax that's
committed
then i'm like reading the i wish you
were just like you know because it
wastes money that's why because i [ __ ]
the ring i [ __ ] waste money
hello hello fly oh most books are
audio books are on youtube fun fact
really don't tell me that because it's
audible
that's not a fun fact so many books we
all signed up after the [ __ ] we
announced it to them here
say don't talk about unless you got a
sponsor well
i mean this channel they haven't
sponsored this in a long time yeah [ __ ]
autumn
i still have audible i love autumn oh
sorry well
you know why i like doing it this way um
even though i'm pirating
it's because youtube has a caption
option and even though sometimes
the words are wrong you can read it fast
forward style
while you're listening to it why don't
you just read the book i do that too but
sometimes the book's not on me i'm like
going like this that's sick yeah that's
it yeah
you can do both you can also legit you
can get them all on youtube right now
a lot of them yeah a lot of them are i
like playing it
as i'm playing animal crossing and then
i'm just listening to a book as i'm
playing animal crossing that's what many
people do
they do podcasts and and games now do
you remember any of it though because
when i do audio books i start drifting
off into space and it's just whenever i
do that
i i rewind like back on my watch or
my phone whatever and i'm like okay [ __ ]
i wasn't paying attention i ended up
getting caught in that thought of the
book
and then i have to go back i had to demo
my bridge to re do the new bridge
i like to write while i read though like
it's
like write the notes down right yeah i
have a notebook and then like
i go oh stop put it into my own words or
like i have a conclusion or i'm like
i have a new idea book reports well it's
not like
if you read non-fiction a lot it's just
like notes on the like if you're gaining
knowledge from it so recently i read a
re-read a stock book
a stock investing book and like just to
brush up on this is it the intelligent
investor
no but i read that one too um benjamin
graham will walk um but
rule number one investing by phil town
he uses warren buffett's strategies and
he just breaks them down into layman's
terms and then he
tells you what tools to like put the
metrics at so you know when to buy one
to sell
after you know which companies to
actually invest in
and he teaches you all that and it's
really cool highly recommend
um every time i've used those strategies
too i've like gone up like 70 to 300
percent
whoa in a few months so the last time i
used it was right before the pandemic
and um the stocks i invested in went up
70
since then that's cool and the first
time i tried it i was 19
and i found crypto i it tripled my
investment within three months
wow because he really teaches you how to
invest like you're gonna own that
company and like how to do the research
before
getting the stock company yeah yeah and
then like
um and then like how to get it at a
margin of safety where it's 50
off the fair value so you're waiting for
it to get
you have to calculate what the fair
price actually is because a lot of
stocks are
undervalued or overvalued so you find
out like what that is and he gives you
all the metrics to find them and then
you wait until it drops because
sometimes the market goes cuckoo like it
did for the pandemic and like it's
probably gonna do again
and all the stock prices are out of
whack and you wait till that price drops
to 50
of the sticker price and then you invest
in it and then so no matter what
even if it goes back to fair value and
then it drops 20 percent you still come
out with 30 percent
or you could be like george soro like as
if you were explaining a mortgage and
i'm like i want to absorb
all of this and it's going in one year
and out the other you have the benefit
of video
you can just replay what you just did
you could you could be like george soros
too and bet that egypt
is going to go under no i don't like i
don't like that i don't like it and then
you
you make egypt go under he's like the
guy at the blackjack table
or another the craps table who bets
against the table and everyone's all
pissed because
he wins but everyone else loses wait but
that's all just a conspiracy because
everything you just said is completely
true but uh they don't really talk about
it very much
that's true but it is a strategy if you
want to invest
yeah forget we said that i don't know
it's
there's so much there's so many ways out
there to make
money and to make money make money and
there's like money money making money
money
do you think that was his plan here the
book the author with the
gaming the system of the book do you
think he would
ultimately be getting more money by
getting in the top
yeah of course you get more visibility i
think it's in the way he was looking at
is maybe an investment he pays for these
400 books
and then you get into this arbitrary
ranking system and then other people see
it and that's a recommendation a lot of
people use recommendations like
publishers
yeah who here that you got in the top 10
or something are more likely to to
repeat
business with you i love watching travel
travel vloggers that are like top 10
best beaches in the world and then you
go oh yeah i'm gonna go there i'm gonna
go there that looks good
dude we do that and that's how we ended
up in this crazy peninsula town in costa
rica
and steve got kidney stones there and we
were stuck
we're hours so you saw all the vlogs
yeah
and it was like literally being in san
diego this is the best beach and we're
like what we left the good beach
is it wasn't blue water it's those
people you know what it is it's those
people
disappointed oh yeah well tourists like
to come here so you don't want to go
there
and actually you want to go to the most
like remote
part where it's like nature nature
there's one there's only tourists go
there for a [ __ ] reason yes
they're like hey don't worry there's
only point five restaurants here you're
like
that sucks no we only want to be able to
have a couple places to go to right
but no no no that's not funny we take
cash and there's no atms in sight and
the water is way colder and you're like
why the [ __ ] do we come here it's a more
legit experience
this is where the locals go that's the
whack of [ __ ]
i don't want to though yeah yeah i'm on
vacation [ __ ] you i want to go
to where it's rare like this is the
whole world locals have to fish to eat
and i'm like
i'm like no but there are special places
in hawaii though that only locals know
about and those are pretty cool they are
cool
you are my dad yeah
and he took us there and we were like
i'm sorry can we go back to the waikiki
we would like to go back to no way
no not really my dad like does the
method of like
this is where all the locals go and then
we go there and it's like i don't see
any locals or anybody like this there's
nobody there oh no you gotta actually
know a local and they teach you and they
go it does this is the secret right here
and then we'll see some like underwater
caves and then there's some all kinds of
crazy [ __ ]
it's fantastic but let me tell you
something unless i can rent a boogie
board next to it i'm out
or like have a cocktail while you're
doing it yeah i'm out
[Music]
you